what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have an update about the
X-Men appearing in Avengers the King
Dynasty and an update about Fantastic
Four casting this is coming today from
Marvel Studios so directly from the
source if you've been following a couple
of the videos or if you've just been
following entertainment regarding Marvel
in general you might know that right now
they are still doing press and
interviews for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania well luckily for us Jeff
lobnes the writer of quantumania is also
writing Avengers the King Dynasty we're
lucky because during these interviews
many people know this fact and keep
asking Jeff lubnis about Kang Dynasty
trying to get any type of details they
can about the movie from him now of
course we know that Kevin feige has a
sniper pointed at everyone's head that
is doing interviews and most people from
Marvel Studios are trained about what to
say what they can and what they can't
say but luckily for us we still are
getting a little bit of information
about the film this time we are getting
some information about whether or not
the X-Men are going to appear in the
King Dynasty or not or if they are even
going to appear in the Multiverse Saga
yes Marvel Studios has begun to tease
mutants or the X-Men in the MCU however
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
new X-Men and the New Mutants are going
to be coming in Phase 5 or phase six
they could be saving them for phase 7.
the next Saga could indeed be a mutant
Saga and what Marvel Studios writer Jeff
loveness had to say kind of hints
towards that in a recent interview with
comicbook.com when asked about key
connections with the Fantastic Four and
the X-Men coming in Avengers the King
Dynasty this is what Jeff lovnes said no
I think all that stuff is pretty far
away I mean I know they're making
Fantastic Four but that's its own thing
so no I mean look I'm the biggest X-Men
guy in the world no no no I think that's
being saved for a bit but you know these
Avengers aren't treble they got a lot
going on with Kang they got more than
enough to handle so it's not looking
like any new X-Men characters or any New
Mutants or Fantastic Four members are
going to be in the Kang Dynasty but this
is what they have kind of been hinting
at before again they're not trying to
give too much away about how the Kang
Dynasty is going to be how Avengers
secret war is going to be and everything
else in between them but at this point
in time we essentially know that the
Kang Dynasty is very much going to be
the next Avengers film it's going to be
a movie about The Avengers and the
heroes from our universe the main MCU
Earth 616 Universe going up against Kang
the Conqueror this is not the big
Multiverse film that is what secret Wars
is for and that is apparently what is
going to happen after the King Dynasty
we've had a few reports and rumors over
the past few months stating that
everything that happens after the King
Dynasty could possibly take place in
other universes of course we'll see
things happening in our universe but a
good majority of what we could see could
take place in other universes watching
other Heroes gather together to go
against Kang and fight him in their
universes then we'll start to see our
heroes and other Heroes start branching
out to other universes to try and form a
giant Avengers team a multiversal heroes
team and this is where we are going to
start to see the X-Men however like
we've mentioned several times on the
channel the X-Men that we see show up in
Avengers Secret Wars than anything else
that involves a Multiverse like Deadpool
3 are going to be the old X-Men from the
fox franchise Hugh Jackman is already
confirmed to be returning and it's said
that Kevin foggy wants the original
X-Men to make it to the MCU because they
never had a chance to actually be a part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe And
since Secret Wars is about universes
colliding well the fox X-Men universe is
one of those universes and there are
plenty of other that have original X-Men
variants in them as well but don't
expect them apparently to show up in the
King Dynasty it looks like this movie is
very much going to be about the Avengers
and Kang and not only that but it's
going going to heavily focus on Kang and
in fact Jeff loveness Compares King the
Conqueror to Magneto stating that we're
kind of going to be rooting for Kang in
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and possibly
even after that and keep in mind Marvel
Studios has recently confirmed that we
are going to be seeing Kang pop up in
other projects before we get to Secret
Wars but in regards to rooting for Kang
this is what Jeff loveness had to say
but I'm willing to bet that we are going
to root for a guy that we've seen
stumble and fall much like Chris
claremont's Magneto from those X-Men
Comics that guy loses a lot and we see
how much pain he's been through and so
by the time he really unleashes his rage
we're on his side and we kind of get it
so I think we're allowed to have a
villain that takes a few shots along the
way as king the Conqueror or his
variants make their rise so it looks
like we are going to see Kang kind of
fail a few times on the MCU before we
get to the actual Kang Dynasty where
apparently we're going to root for him
which I am all for because I love
Jonathan Major's portrayal of King the
Conqueror and I'm really looking forward
to seeing more variants now Jeff
loveness also did say that the Fantastic
Four they're not going to be in the King
Dynasty either he said in regards to the
Fantastic Four he probably won't even be
using them and in this interview he said
that they are their own thing but having
said that about the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four not being in the King
Dynasty keep in mind that Marvel Studios
could be misleading us intentionally
it's not deceptive in a bad way it's so
we don't actually know what's going to
happen and so everything isn't spoiled
which of course we understand but we
bring this up because of course just
because they say it doesn't mean it's
actually how it's going to happen a lot
of us guess that Avengers 4 was going to
be called Avengers end game then the
Russo Brothers came out and said nope
that's not the title but lo and behold
it was so even though the X-Men and the
Fantastic Four probably aren't going to
be in the King Dynasty there is still a
small chance that they could be and
speaking of the Fantastic Four like I
mentioned we do have a casting update
not particularly about any specific
actor that could be cast for a role in
The Fantastic Four but how Marvel
Studios and Kevin feige are approaching
it Matt shackman who is going to be
directing the Fantastic Four in an
interview with deadline opened up a
little bit about the Fantastic Four now
a couple of weeks ago he said in another
interview that they have nothing to
announce right now implying that the
Fantastic Four have not yet been cast
but in another interview with deadline
this is what he said
just to be clear even if something is
getting active or gearing up could still
be weeks or even months before we have
our four actors given how thorough
Marvel Studios and Kevin feige are so
Matt shackman confirms here Kevin feige
is personally overseen casting for the
Fantastic Four which makes a ton of
sense because this is his baby this is
Kevin feige's passion project so he's
going to be involved in the process a
lot but unfortunately according to Matt
shackman it does seem like we are a
little bit out from getting an official
announcement about who the Fantastic
forecast actually is but the fact that
the studio was so involved in that Kevin
feige is so involved makes us think that
the Fantastic Four truly are going to be
a major staple of the MCU moving forward
Reed Richards Sue storm Johnny Storm and
Ben Grimm are going to be major
characters moving forward in the next
Saga they are essentially going to be
our Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man our
Chris Evans Captain America Chris
Hemsworth as Thor and so on and so forth
these are going to be major characters
moving forward so the casting process of
figuring out who they are you know it's
going to be pretty rigorous which is a
really great thing and I have to say I
think it's also a good thing that no
mutants or the Fantastic Force show up
in the King Dynasty that way Secret Wars
is on that bigger scale if we see the
entire Multiverse kind of fight and we
see the heroes come together in Avengers
the King Dynasty then Secret Wars
wouldn't be that much different it
wouldn't be that much bigger but
containing the King Dynasty 2 our
Avengers team and our universe fighting
one or maybe a couple different variants
of Kang that is not only going to be
incredibly exciting but it's going to
massively build up the next film but
Marvel Studios knows what they're doing
so we are going to trust them for the
Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars but in the
meantime let us know what you think
about no X-Men and no Fantastic Four in
the Kang Dynasty let us know your
thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on the latest MCU news you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching wolf